ah
here we are okay
um
so this will be completely different
maybe to
what you're used to on conferences it's
not
practical the first point uh it's a bit
like mind blowing maybe
uh if you haven't had coffee i think
this is the same
effect so it will wake you up uh
yeah but first of all it's really nice
to be here in budapest
i've been here the last time about 20
years ago
so it's quite a long time ago and
before i was here with my parents when i
was 16 it was exactly the name
the day when they opened the border to
um
to austria so i'm from the eastern part
of germany so it was really
okay now something is changing and now
i'm back and i'm really happy to be here
okay so this is me um i'm working at ubi
labs i'm one of the founder
and head of development we are a company
focused on
implementing the google maps api and
we're working with a really
big amount of data big amount of code
base
and usually have to deal with really
like a lot of
aspects in our like work um but this
talk will be
about not my day work or what i do
during uh during the daytime but more
about what they're doing
at night so what i'm doing when i'm at
home and i have some free time to hack
on new stuff so
as i work with maps i said about like
two
years ago let's create a map library
that fits
into 1024 characters so exactly 1k
without any dependencies and i wrote
this kind of script
you might have seen it so this is the
source code you see
there's a script tag in the top that
goes to the button you have some code
inside and then you have the world or
globe in in there
and once you open it up on the web
browser
without any dependencies you will see
this
so you will see a spinning 3d globe
that turns around and you also have like
color coding for the
for the um the library around and yeah
that's it so this is how i started
somehow
i did some smaller projects before but
that's basically
how i got more famous um
another thing i did is this kind of
project
it's called monday code so it has the
shape of a monday pro
and once you open it in a browser it
looks like this and you have to click
once
and once you activate it um you see an
animated
monthly port that goes really deep
inside
it's really cool it takes like two yeah
thanks
so it zooms in further and further until
it reaches the limit where the
javascript
values can't like a difference anymore
and you see the whole thing will break
into parts which you see in maybe some
seconds
um so here you see
things are going crazy and then that's
the maximum amount of like um
resolution that you get into numbers in
javascript
another thing i focus on after um
thinking about okay how many or what
you can get into a specific amount of
character was the opposite question and
the question was okay
how many characters or how many
different characters do we need to
write javascript and it turns out there
was a discussion somewhere else i i'm
not
in the in the original discussion but
i fixed it and set up a website and it
turns out that you only have to need
um of parenthesis a plus sign square
brackets and ampersand
and i set up jsfuck.com where you can
put
in any javascript that you like for
example edit one
and it will encode you the data into
this
sequence of characters and you can take
sequence and copy it somewhere and it
will run without a transpiler or
something
so it's valid javascript that will
execute
and this is a lot one in this case so
it's quite a lot of characters that you
need but it's only six different
characters
um before we go on i
want to show you how to do this
modification stuff so it's called
code golfing and there are like many
different languages where you can do it
and i usually focus on
html and javascript and one thing that
you always need around is html
that is really small and actually it's
something i would call
dynamic html5 so it's like the best of
both worlds and
to show you this is a common known
template
um but actually if we focus on this
and if you wanna really have small sized
html then we can skip the doctype
we can get rid of the html tag we don't
need a hat
we don't need a title because we just
have something there
and we can also get rid of the type in
the script tag
we we then can
skip the script itself and just place
everything in
on load handler and if we have this then
we don't need the closing body because
the browser
does it for you so this is like a really
minimal set
that you need and if you look at this
we can also skip the quotes if you don't
have a space in between so
that's cool um
what can we do now so an easy example
would be okay
allot1 allot something this will pop up
something
i use this example later for some more
general
templates and if we want to have
something in the html we can use
document write which is
a short way to do something the problem
here is that you can't
do things on animation so if you want to
have an animated html
like i wanna add you can't use this
because document right will always
append stuff to the
document but we could use document body
inner html
something it's quite long because the
document body is so
massive um but we can fix this by saying
okay
body has an id b and we have access to
this id
b in the javascript and this is
something
many people don't know but once you
define an id
in in a dom or in html
it's available on a global scope in
javascript
as long as you don't override it so no
you need for
jquery anymore just use the id
and then you're good um
i usually want to have it somewhere
formatted so
i want to have like shaped output and
i don't include css because css is
usually
too massive and you need this extra
style tag around
um so what i do is use the pretag
in this example or yeah
and um the problem here is uh once you
have this
um greater than sign inside of an
unload handler then the browser thinks
okay the
attack is ended here so it will output
a one and to fix this we have to get
back the quotes here and if you focus on
this example then we see okay there's
one
byte to save one character to save and
that's
the space between the id and b and if we
simply change
the order and move the idb to the back
and remove the space then it's working
two
because the attribute is closed and we
don't need the space anymore
okay this is one way to do it another
way to do it would be to
place the pre-tag in the beginning of
the html with an id
and then include a script with
like the reference to it and used inner
html to update this
that's about html
let's see what's possible in in um
javascript so this is really basic stuff
um there's a
wiki about like all the crazy
magnification
um on the 140 bytes github project
um but this is to give you an idea of
what's
like possible and if you take this
simple example so we have x
y and z and we have random values and
then we get the maximum value of both of
them
and because we don't care about global
leakage we can skip the va
here we can use m
as a reference to math and then replace
the math with the m
so to save some space we can do the same
for the random things so we say
r is m dot random and then get
rid of the long call here
and when so this should be obvious but
it's getting interesting now once you
specify
um the random method not with the
dot syntax but as a string you can say
okay
i have the string random and let's call
the method with this string on math
and it looks longer but once you
look into this you can save another
space by
moving the definition inside of the
first
assignment so you get this
in there and save some space and one
thing that you also can do is use
the not recommended with it
you can skip the skip the curly braces
if you use the comma syntax and then
you can do the same for the random thing
and
if you um shrink this together you
get this in the end so that's what you
get
after like working hard manually so
there's no way to do this automatically
or there are some ways to do it but it's
like all done by hand in this case
um yeah
i was playing around with this kind of
minification and
about a year ago i came up with an idea
after looking into
um into my js i realized that i
could replace some characters with other
characters and
i created something called death star
and this is the output so this is an
html file it has the shape of a russian
star
and if you look close you see okay
there's a body unload on the top
and this is the script that will execute
you see
there's no like obvious method in there
it's only
correlated alphabet and some symbols
here
and in the center there's this star and
once you open it it gives you
an error with this so it's like an alert
one but
with the unicode star and
another example i'm gonna explain how
this works in a second so
wait a second um another thing i did for
the first time is
writing hebrew javascript so you have to
read it from
right to left to get it and it's also
like valid javascript
just paste it in console and it will
output one
and what i did too is this kind of stuff
so it looks like it's written from up to
down but actually it's
using tabs to separate this this
characters this is um
katakana and it reminded me a bit
about an intro of a famous movie so i
created for js com
asia last year this kind of project it's
called the matrix
and yeah it's like it's using
canvas in this case and you see like
something that
you might have seen in an intro sequence
of the matrix movie
and if you look close you see that this
is the source code itself so
the script goes from top to bottom and
in there it's only using asian
characters
to to execute this code
okay the question now was how to write
javascript
without latin characters so this is
that's the thing give me a second
um okay so there are two ways to do it
escape sequences
and playing scrabble as i call it um
i'm gonna place this here so um we start
with escape sequences
they're quite easy if you have on
character a for example you could
also write backslash u and then a
unicode
hexadecimal value for the character and
it will
like run it as you expect
there's another way to do this oh no if
you combine this for example if you
write this in
in javascript it's actually add one so
it's like valid javascript another way
to do it is to use like
or a good way to use it it's to use for
higher
characters um from in this case the
rain character in in the kanji
or chinese alphabet
[Music]
but you could also use um a backslash x
for lower values in the ascii
character set to to write like anything
you like
the problem here is that you have to use
it in quotes so you can't use it
like everywhere around you have to use
it in
in a string um so we have backslash
x and then the hex code and some people
don't know this but there's also a way
to use octal sequences so you only have
a backslash and then
um from zero to seven just eight
different um
numbers to to write anything you like
yeah for example this is also alert one
so it uses only symbols
numbers and backslash and if you look at
this you have this different
number sequences and these are the octa
representation of the of the um
characters that are in this case map
constructor alert so
if i wrote it in one line it's it's this
code basically
and this is like a core thing that we
need to do all the
all the other hacks i have to explain it
because
if you have an empty area and you access
the map
method or you could also say filter or
sword or whatever
then it's basically a function and if
you get the constructor
of a function you get this function
constructor and there you can pass like
any code you like
and it will execute so in this
case it would be something like an eval
and that's a good way because you can
hide and eval
in other characters yeah
okay so we had s-cap sequences and the
next thing to do it would be to use
scrabble kind of things so um
it's a basic um idea that i found
at the js project so if you say
not an empty array you get forward spec
if you say not not an empty hours you
get true
and if you add an empty string here
you get the string false and the string
tool
yeah and what you can do then is to get
different characters here
so for example i got the first one to
get the t
the r the u and the e if you use the
different numbers here
and if you mix them up for example the
first or fourth the second or fourth
the third of two the first of through
and the sec the
character at position zero from through
then you see
a pattern if you move it around you see
okay we got this alert here
[Applause]
and this is really powerful so that's
why i call it scrabble so scrabble would
be false object true false object object
false true
um and there it's not possible to get
all characters only a subset
but the cool thing is that you get a
constructor out of it so you can
you have this undefined here untrue
fault and object and these are used to
to get these different characters that
are needed for constructor and if you
combine them
then you are able to do this map
constructor alert by just adding
different
characters together so that's a basic
idea
um so i thought about
what's possible in like 1k what's
possible with
only six different characters how to
write
code in in other alphabets so without
latin characters
for example hebrew or asian characters
and the next step
i thought of would be okay how to do
this
um how to write code that's actually
invisible
and i come up with a quite simple idea
or the question was how can we hide
javascript inside itself
and the basic idea here was to use white
scale
white space there's actually some quite
simple tricks
that you only use like spaces and tabs
and new line characters and you use this
to encode your
script um and
if you look at this characters then you
see that
and if you look at the hex codes here
then you see that they are
really one of the first 16
characters in the ascii definition so
these are all
control characters some are known some
are not known
and the problem is that most of them
once you place them into the code
you still see them so they are blank but
they
take a width so a space is a space a tab
is like four or eight spaces and the new
line is a new line
um but if you look further and go to the
next page
you see a list of ctrl characters
that are quite strange i'm not sure if
they are used somewhere in
in the javascript but the cool thing
here is
they don't have a width so they are zero
with characters so
you can place them in your code and no
one
would ever see that there is something
hidden um
i created a project called zero it's up
here
and the source code is this so it's
about like 80 characters wide
and you see some strange eval eval
escape replays magic
and if you open this page you will see
this
so this is canvas game of life
done in this amount of characters and
it's like a thousand iteration
until it reaches a stable level
and when you look at the code
um the uncompressed code or like if you
look at the code in an editor
that's able to display um hex values you
see this
and inside of this is
something hidden that's generating this
game of life code
and this is about like 200 characters
and the magic happens here
because in the first escape um statement
there's an empty string or it looks like
an empty string
so there's something here and this will
be escaped and replaced
by a new sequence of the third and six
characters
combined with an x in front of it
so so that's a basic idea so we have 16
different
um contour characters um
if you use a random sequence here like
this or it's not random
as you see in a moment and then you say
escape
you get this sequence and then we gonna
replace the ampersand and the one
to get only the relevant numbers here
and we join them in groups by two like
this
and place an x in front of it and once
we
execute this or eval this we get a lot a
lot one
and like whatever you like so you can
hide
anything in there and as much code as
you want
yeah so i'm usually developing using
chrome and i was really happy with the
results uh
until i came to another browser
where they had this flag mods control
character visibility visible
so this is how it looks in chrome
and when you open it in firefox you see
this
yeah and i was really disappointed after
like weeks of work
i thought okay
and i did some research and found this
quote within mozilla some people like
the idea of displaying control
characters
yeah i i thought of yeah
let's play the game on the next level so
i've been to a conference in minsk
um about a month ago and i created
something new and
i picked a theme
the theme was tetris so tetris is a
russian game or from a russian inventor
and the name itself is tetra antenna so
it
contains titra is like the prefix of
four and tennis is the game tennis
so i set up a code that looks like this
i spread it a bit and divided it
and as you see here you have the script
tag
around um you have only
numbers in there and different um
symbols and the whole board is divided
by
this inline comments
and inside of this i have a space with
like different
empty dots here and once you execute
it in a browser you would see that the
docs are filled by an
block so there's a block moving down and
you can use the
the keyboard to control it and you can
actually like play a simple version of
tetris you can you can move it
and once you have a full line as you see
here
it disappears so so i call it binary
tetris because it's really like
based on some atomic parts
um the code itself if you reformat it it
looks like this
the first two lines are the well-known
map constructor
thing to evolve anything you like and
then
you have in here another
eval and escape sequence and a replays
and what we did before was using the
third and sixth character to join them
with a
leading x and what we need now is
like getting the six characters and join
them in groups by three
so to give you an idea this is what we
had before
but now we can only use like eight
different numbers here
and um i found an ask uh no in utf
uh udf8 character uh one four four
zero and a sequence uh that we can use
to
to write this kind of code and the
characters look like this
and if you zoom up there they look
really strange and they're called chants
or cantillation marks and they're used
for
in the in the hebrew language to specify
like
rhythmic speaking and the cool thing
about it is
once you combine them they don't have a
space too so they just stack
together it's quite cool because you can
then combine them into a single
like empty string
yeah and if you have this example and
we escape it we got that if we only take
the
six characters out we still have the the
numbers here
we then combine it into blocks of three
put the backslash and then we have the
octal encoding
for the for the different characters and
if we combine them
we still have the uh alert one
yeah so this is the basic idea the
tetris itself
is quite simple i just want to say i
just want to show you how this works
um this is the source code for tetris so
if you don't have to
like pack it somewhere um
so we have embody an unload and a
prescript with an id
that we can use to like fill we have a
set interval
and where we listen to on key down
events
and this code is used to like control
the blocks
the next block here is used to to render
the whole board
so it converts the characters and
renders blocks and new lines and dots
and inside here it's really short so
this is the
the logic itself for tetra so it cares
about
like moving and collision detection and
also about um like
removing blank lines and if you look
close here
there's a lot of binary and shift
magic going on and to explain you the
idea
is i wanted to have a board
that looks like this and this board
could be written like um
with a binary representation so whenever
we have
a hash then we use a one and whenever we
have a dot
we use the zeros and this is actually
then a number that we can use and this
number 192
can be used to do some
bite shifting things and if we shift by
five it goes down line if we say shift
uh by one or minus one then it goes left
and right
and if you use um the
bitwise and we can use it to detect
collision
so and that's basically what you need to
to get it done
and get it running yeah and the final
result is this
so you can play tetris and only i think
it's
240 bytes of javascript and html
okay we're almost done five minutes left
um everyone i want to show some work in
progress so it's not done i
tried to finished it but i wasn't in
time
but i want to give you impressions so
this is something i'm currently working
on it's called the aleph
and this is like because i'm going to a
conference in
tel aviv in about two weeks and this is
using using hebrew characters only
and it packs the whole logic in a single
in a single character in the top
another thing i played around with is
this code it looks really strange but
it's valid javascript too
so it uses um combining characters that
stack over each other so you can still
execute this and like run any code you
like and it's like
vertical layout that you have
yeah that's about it
thank you
no i'm not not not finished it's about
just that's that's the thing i i want to
like
answer some questions before you do okay
the question is why do
do i do this and i think it's
it has many aspects one are the
limitations that you're
using so you have this really limitation
of like a specific amount of characters
that you have to use there's no
way to bypass it and you really have to
work
through this limitation and you have to
like focus on this
um so focus is another thing so if you
have an idea
then you can only take the
most important part of the idea out of
it so there's no room for like
packing stuff into it and this is
something i take away to to my
daily work because when someone asks me
especially clients oh can we have this
and that then it's always good to say
okay no we have to focus
and that's good um another thing is
structure so the the code itself it
looks really unreadable
but if you write it you really have to
structure it so it's like
pages but it's really it's not wide so
it's narrow but it's like really long
and you
need tools to reformat it and find ways
to do this automatically
and i think one of the most important
part it's fun so it's really cool to
create and hack this kind of projects
and it's also cool to see what other
people do
and it's it's a good way to
like live your creativity and it's good
to do something
with javascript or with other languages
outside of your daily work job
and what i like most here is it's a
really nice community
so you might have seen some demo
demos like our school demos and there
the community was always really close so
everyone
was we did a cool demo he didn't want to
show the into source code so
now it's changing and everyone in the
javascript community set up a github
project
and talks about it and you can see the
source code and
everyone writes blog posts about it and
giving talks
and i would say okay now it's up to you
to go out and just
do something not work related just for
fun
just for creativity and yeah
so that's it basically and um
have a look at this site's js1k is a
contest
where you like create stuff and 1000
characters or
one chair you have this 140 bytes
project um there is powered
it's an odd school website and there's
something new coming up it's called
called shader toy and they use webgl
shaders to create really stunning demos
so have a look at this
and yeah go out and play
so thanks
well i don't know what you think but i
my mind is blowing and i can't
even brain right now um that was amazing
i am so impressed uh we have some
questions from twitter which is pretty
great uh the first question is what was
the best tweet site
twit size minify javascript you've came
across
did you make a 140 character one and if
yes what was it
um so the 140 by
things so so this is another project i
just mentioned it
um it's initial in an initiative by
judgment so he said okay let's
try to hack something that's well at
javascript it's not
leaking globally and so it should
be some libraries that you can use in
your daily project in your daily work
and i came in with
a base64 encoder so this was how i get
involved too
and i ended with the tetris so the logic
in inside of of tetris inside of 140
characters
and but there were so many and so many
different
projects so people really great
tiny libraries made out of this um there
was an ask parser or like a new language
um parser that's written in like
different parts of
140 bytes project so it was really like
stunning what's possible
so the next question is how do you debug
in a visible
hand minified code
to debug it um the thing is
usually i don't write them all by hand
so i don't open up a hex
editor and do this so i have tools that
will convert stuff like this
and it's a long pro process change so
it's like um
there's ugly 5.js involved there are
some other tools that will replace stuff
and i have my own ascii art generator
where i have like a
bitmap and it scales and tries to
replace characters by different
points of the code and it tries to eval
this kind of stuff so there
is a really long code chain and it took
some time to get it
are there any other questions from the
audience
yeah there's one over there we can get a
mic over there in the back
hello thanks a lot um is it possible to
see
the tools that you use somewhere on
github or something like that
um yeah sure so i have mine
my project so my my website is hosted on
github
i have like all the stuff i do on github
it's not well documented so
they are tools so i usually try to hack
it really fast to get it
work work and running and
i have to clean it up but there are
other projects or other people that
really good
in in this kind of two chains and there
was a recent
um submission in in the js1k contest
and i think it was i have to look it up
maybe i'm gonna tweet about this but
there are some cool two chains to use
yeah use your homework write your
documentation
is there another question or is that
someone just starting
because i can't really tell hey someone
in the back i'm sorry but
for the hey i don't know any more
questions one more question
come on there's one over there
oh and there are two would you ever use
it in a production
sorry would you would you ever use
or what you shown us in production um no
actually not
so okay okay so maybe that's
two two cases so one would be to test
your security aspects so you can use
this jsf
code for example to test if it's really
safe
for xss attacks but
[Music]
i think it's not needed to to be in the
production code because there are always
like ways to
to unescape it and to find way to like
read what's going on there
so there's no no way to hide it at all
because you can spend some effort to to
get it so just a short follow-up so
what would be the your perfect way of
hiding the code so no one can read it
and
kind of copy it or steal it
so the perfect way to hide code yeah
um i think it's a combination so
and i would only do it to hide it to
to make people learn how to uh
like reveal it so there's a cool website
act no net i think it's called this 3d
css experience and here's some really
cool hidden code and you have to go
through and you see
um he's overriding the eval and the
escape
methods and then restoring it so he uses
us
his own custom methods and he also uses
um characters from the hebrew
alphabet that changes the reading
direction so you can't read the code
anymore because it's like
you start from one and and it's flipping
in between so it's really hard to see
what's going on
cheers okay i've seen one more question
somewhere here yes
and then you actually get to get some
coffee so don't worry
although i would imagine everyone is
really awake right now
you hear me have you done this kind of
stuff in
other languages and in general
what do you think in javascript with
this regard is it
what stuff do you like what you don't
like about the language
um so i haven't done that in other
languages i only focus on the javascript
part
i saw some really cool things going on i
think pisces is really
good for this and ruby and so there's
some japanese guy
creating really crazy stuff with ruby
code
um there are some
i think this this js1k not not just okay
this js so six different characters
i think javascript is the
language where you can do this there's
no other language
or at least i think there's no other
language where you can really
only use six different symbols
but there are other language languages
like like ruby that
provide some more functionality by
default so you can use
like unpack algorithms that are already
included
somewhere so javascript is okay
and for me it's quite fun and the cool
thing about javascript is that
if you combine it with html there's an
immediate output
so you can see it in a browser and
that's that's what's cool so usually all
the other examples you have to compile
it or copy it to the command line and
javascript box in the browser okay cool
thanks
awesome thank you for all the questions
and thank you martin that was absolutely
amazing
and i hope that everyone is really like
eager to
work on some fun projects with
javascript and now everyone gets coffee
which is even more exciting
thank you
you